i
[Música]
la tormenta fiona ya se convirtió en
huracán ante la inminente llegada de
este fenómeno a puerto rico el
presidente de eeuu joe biden declaró el
estado de emergencia en este territorio
estadounidense del caribe
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi
llego armenia este sábado liderando una
comisión parlamentaria desde washington
pelosi señaló que eeuu debe estar del
lado de armenia en referencia al
conflicto con azerbaiyán
a menos de 24 horas del funeral de la
reina isabel segunda miles de personas
continúan esperando para despedirse de
la monarca en filas que han alcanzado
los 8 kilómetros mientras tanto líderes
mundiales van llegando a londres para la
ceremonia de mañana tenemos reporteros
buenos días bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 en español soy ruso pérez
más de hoy y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles empezamos la tormenta
tropical fiona ya se convirtió en
huracán y ante la llegada inminente de
este fenómeno a puerto rico el
presidente de estados unidos joe biden
declaró el estado de emergencia para
este territorio estadounidense del
caribe baiden pidió al departamento de
seguridad nacional movilizar todos los
esfuerzos necesarios para evitar una
catástrofe una medida que llega tras la
solicitud tramitada ayer por el
gobernador de puerto rico que también
anunció la apertura de decenas de
refugios veamos cómo se prepara la
población temerosa de volver a vivir la
devastación causada por el huracán maría
en 2017
creo que hemos aprendido bastante de eso
pensando
y mira lo que pasó
vamos tarde con todo y eso comparando la
planta ahora
esto realmente de nuevo pues ya ustedes
saben cómo ven que se van
bueno
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi
llegó a armenia este sábado liderando
una comisión parlamentaria desde
washington se trata de la visita del
político estadounidense de mayor rango
al país desde que obtuvo su
independencia hace 30 años en ereván
pelosi afirmó que eeuu debe apoyar a
armenia en el conflicto con azerbaiyán
mientras que bakú rechazó las
declaraciones de la estadounidense y
aseguró que no contribuyen a la paz
regional de hecho la visita de pelosi
llega tras la reanudación de las
hostilidades entre ambos países cuando
cerca de 200 personas han muerto en los
recientes combates y en un momento en
que tanto la unión europea como rusia
mantienen intereses económicos con
azerbaiyán
link en nuestra reunión nuevamente tuvo
una importancia particular para nosotros
debido al enfoque de seguridad luego de
los ataques ilegales y mortales de
azerbaiyán en el territorio armenio
condenamos enérgicamente esos ataques
nosotros y nuestra delegación en nombre
y que amenazan las perspectivas de un
muy necesario acuerdo de paz
vamos con información relacionada con la
guerra en ucrania cuando las fuerzas de
kiev retomaron y sium en la región
oriental de jarquín esta semana
encontraron decenas de fosas comunes con
los cuerpos de personas muertas
supuestamente bajo la ocupación rusa las
tropas ucranianas hallaron más de 400
cadáveres que están siendo examinados
para determinar las causas exactas de
las defunciones en este contexto el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
volvió a acusar a moscú de cometer actos
de tortura de misión como hizo en lucha
vale no más o poco van a se están
realizando exámenes de los cuerpos se
encontraron nuevas pruebas de la tortura
infringidas contra las personas
enterradas allí en áreas liberadas de la
región dejar que se han encontrado más
de 10 cámaras de tortura en varias
ciudades y pueblos
la situación en la línea del frente no
tuvo cambios significativos durante el
último día las fuerzas armadas de
ucrania las unidades de nuestra
inteligencia el servicio secreto las
unidades de la guardia nacional están
empujando gradualmente paso a paso a los
habitantes fue de nuestra tierra soto
training cambiamos de información en
irán decenas de personas protestaron
contra la brutalidad policial en el
funeral de macsa amin y la joven que
murió tras ser arrestada por la llamada
policía de la moral la mujer de 22 años
fue detenida por no llevar el 'hiyab'
correctamente
cantos de muerte al dictador mientras el
dolor se convierte en rabia en el
funeral de más ánimo para los dolientes
hay pocas dudas sobre quién mató a la
joven de 22 años acusan a la policía de
la moral de irán de haber golpeado a la
mujer hasta la muerte
una afirmación negada por las
autoridades
hasta ahora no hay pruebas de que las
autoridades le hayan pegado estamos
siguiendo de cerca este asunto para ver
si ha habido algún golpe técnicamente
las policías de la moral no tienen
herramientas para golpear son tienen
porras ni ninguna otra herramienta en la
voz tu mirada navas y lidera las
autoridades tienen una versión diferente
de los hechos respaldada dicen por esta
grabación que parece haber sido editada
más y fue detenida por no cumplir el
estricto código de vestimenta iraní la
policía afirma que tuvo un problema de
salud mientras esperaba en una comisaría
de la moral con otros detenidos dicen
que tuvo un ataque al corazón pero su
familia niega que sufriera de alguna
enfermedad cardíaca en las imágenes
parece que se desploma mientras habla
con otras personas más tarde murió en el
hospital el presidente de irán prometió
una investigación completa sin embargo
su muerte ha vuelto a poner en el punto
de mira a la policía de la moral iraní y
sus estrictas leyes que obligan a las
mujeres a cubrirse el pelo ya llevar
ropa holgada en los últimos meses
activistas de derechos humanos han
instado a las mujeres a quitarse el velo
para desafiar el código de vestimenta
islámico de gran en reino unido- van
llegando los líderes internacionales
invitados al funeral de la reina isabel
segunda que se celebrará mañana en
londres entre ellos el presidente de
eeuu joe biden la presidenta de la
comisión europea úrsula von der leyen o
el rey de españa felipe sexto
paralelamente la capital británica se
prepara para el mayor funeral de estado
de las últimas décadas con un
dispositivo de seguridad sin precedentes
previamente en nuestra corresponsal
luisa pulido nos amplió más desde
londres
16 horas exactamente quedan para que la
capilla ardiente de isabel segunda sea
cerrada su ser a las 6 y 30 de la mañana
--hora local-- horas antes de que sea
llevada transportada al parla a la
abadía de westminster donde será el
funeral como lo menciona es el tiempo de
espera ya es de 14 horas y el gobierno
advertido que quienes quieran sumarse a
la fila en estos momentos ya no podrán
ingresar a la abadía rendir su tributo
personal a la reina isabel así que las
personas que ustedes pueden ver a mis
espaldas en este momento están
tranquilas se sienten emocionadas en
este punto quedan todavía varias horas
han hecho fila por seis horas las
personas que ustedes pueden ver aquí
dicen estar emocionadas y esperar que
puedan llegar
justamente al westminster hall pero lo
cierto es que están respirando porque ya
ven cerca el parlamento pero todavía les
queda tiempo les cuento que además las
temperaturas han empezado a bajar así
que los equipos logísticos que están
acompañando a todas las personas ha
traído cobijas para que ellos puedan
estar un poco con un poco más de
temperatura en estas horas y los
servicios médicos han atendido a mil
personas que se han desmayado
desde el jueves haciendo las filas
y cerramos en europa porque este fin de
semana se celebran en francia las
jornadas europeas del patrimonio una
oportunidad para visitar lugares de
interés cultural que no suelen estar
abiertos al público
ocultos entre los muros de este hospital
parisino documentos históricos que el
público puede ver por primera vez este
hospital especializado en afecciones
oftalmológicas fue inaugurado en el
siglo 13 por el rey luis noveno
y resulta muy emotivo encontrar las
instrucciones escritas que dio el rey de
risa hace más de 700 años y que
conciernen a un establecimiento que
sigue atendiendo hoy en día a personas
que sufren deficiencias visuales
en las jornadas del patrimonio de este
año la atención se centra en explorar
los retos a los que se enfrentan estos
lugares de interés en función del cambio
climático este año muchas ciudades
también ponen el foco en mujeres
creadoras en el pasado el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón creó la lotería
del patrimonio hace cinco años a quien
querer un teatro del siglo 19 que lleva
cuatro décadas vacío recibirá 500 mil
euros procedentes de esta iniciativa y
desde el 2018 se han salvado 745 lugares
en peligro tanto en francia como en el
extranjero por lo que es una campaña
extraordinaria que ha sido posible
gracias a esta lotería y que enriquece y
da visibilidad a las asociaciones
locales
en el programa se ha insertado además
una mirada entre los bastidores de
notredame para observar las técnicas de
restauración que se utilizan tras el
devastador incendio de 2019
muchas gracias por su atención
sigan con nosotros
[Música]